c'est officiel matt pokora donc est de
retour cette semaine après des mois
d'absence active états unis le chanteur
annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux
la venue d'un nouvel album à ce que les
prochaines tournées c'est le pire à mes
tours regardez les sujets et puis
ensuite on va en parler ce qui fait un
tout petit peu pas scandale mais ce
qu'est né un petit peu les les les fans
c'est que heroes vient et il annonce
directement l'ouverture de la
billetterie pour un grand concert et
août une tournée alors qu'il ya même pas
l'album la seule qui faisait ça c'était
katy perry est ce que matt pokora peut
se permettre de le faire aussi on en
discute juste après regardez aïe ça
pique un peu les sur m pokora est de
retour et il a dévoilé cette semaine le
teaser de sa future tournée
matt pokora pyramide petit film d'une
mine qui a suscité chez nous quelques
interrogations
ainsi le fan de claude françois se
présente il désormais comme un véritable
voyageur intergalactique en pleine
résurrection
voyez donc le pharaon strasbourgeois de
32 ans débarquons d'une autre planète
avec les moustaches de freddie mercury
et la veste de michael jackson
contemplant fièrement la foulée bailly
s'est sublimé pas du tout mégalo on nage
en pleine science-fiction
mélangez un soupçon de strangers inc
pour le côté branché et une pincée d'x
men apocalypse pour la superproduction à
croire que matt pokora nous préparerait
en plus de sa tournée sa propre série en
cachette alors matt pokora n'en fait il
pas un peu trop
enfin
ce que
voilà matt pokora donc pour juste en
quelques chiffres
il a fait l'album de reprises de claude
françois c'est un énorme carton 400000
ventes et il a gagné 3 millions d'euros
environ qui ont été mérités il a fait
une tournée qui est un carton il prenait
20000 euros par soir il est parti aux
états unis à environ un an et voilà il
annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux comme on
l'a vu ici un teaser on sait pas ce que
c'est ce que c'était pendant que ce
teaser cas c'est magnifique on vient
d'apprendre que donc c'est pour
l'annoncé d'une tournée alors que pour
l'instant il n'y a pas encore d'album
qui devrait sortir d'ici un an donc est
ce qu'ils n'en fait pas un peu trop de
retour à l'américaine la katy perry et
tout ça on vous a posé la question
oui il en fait trop pour myriam palombes
à myriam oui d'un bug totalement ses
limites à la limite du ridicule un
excusez moi mais c'est vrai on a
l'impression que c'est le messie qui
revient sur terre mais qui attendait
pokora ben voilà attendez on écoute on
écoute on écoute la dernière fois qu'il
s'est pris pour un américain s'cusez moi
quand il a voulu me faire son album à la
timberlake ça a été un flop total on n'a
plus entendu parler de lui pendant trois
ans mercy merial est rhabillé pour
l'hiver mathieu c'est la cuma thé vous
pensez c'est moi qui fais ça tu es
parodie au départ j'y tiens c'est un
sketch des inconnus qui reviennent ouais
la pyramide pourquoi c'est le pharaon
quoi il se prend pour un phare ont le
souci des mousses pourquoi c'est qu'il
est très populaire et dans ce très bien
qu'ils ont très bien mais vous allez
dans la rue vous demandez à des adultes
de citer un seul titre de lui personne
n'est capable
non c'est qu'ils soient je sais pas je
sais pas ce que sa gamme pokora si ce
n'est qu'un grand professionnel mais
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière je sais pas
vous savez quoi refaire le test avec une
personne qui va bientôt avoir 52 ans qui
entend encore qui voit pas mal malgré
ses lunettes triple foyer mi-homme
imputés
à part tout ce qui me reste guillaume à
titre je suis fou de toi un bon merci
guillaume pour le coup vous êtes dur
parce qu'il a beaucoup on me dit que le
monde tourne autour de moi
on s'en fout que matt pokora moi j'ai
pas acheté un disque de bruel s'est pas
jeté dans les eaux johnny j'ai pas
acheté les disques de l'ue j'achète pas
ses disques je sais que j'aime non je ne
faut pas faire les oppresse je me suis
abonné à un truc payant je je ce que je
veux dire c'est que matt pokora
j'adore ce type parce que il bosse il
est sain quand il fait ça m'a bien
clients mais oui les cinq des normes à
des amis repart dans le sud qui n'ont
abattant les couleurs mais je veux dire
c'est que c'est un bon gars c'est il est
à l'américaine il bosse comme un dingue
il fait des comédies musicales ça marche
alors oui c'est ça il ya plein de trucs
qui fait des séries fait un truc sur m6
une émission de télé sa splendeur fait
notre sur tf1 sa marge en tant que
justement est-ce que et ont même bien
esclaves vraie qualité cd pas d'être
justement humble c'est un garçon qui est
toujours resté un malgré son succès
est-ce que là il s'abîme pas un petit
peu en faisant ça ce qu'ils ont fait
rire d'euros c'est délicieusement
ringard on est d'accord mais oui mais le
prince a créé le buzz
et puis je vous voulez que je vous dise
le jeu super soit déclassé ça sera plein
son truc hein ça dans son spectacle je
vous dis que ce matin la dernière
prédiction c'est catherine rambert donné
je t'attends magali taunay la parole
pourquoi vous trouvez sébastien bou
qu'il en fait il en fait trop sur ce
coup là bas et là j'ai l'impression
qu'il a passé un peu trop de temps aux
états unis alors je comprends il est là
bas il est il a été un peu trop imprégné
de la culture américaine
et là c'est un peu délirant pour moi
c'est plus un chanteur de reprise pour
le moment on attend on n'a même pas
entendu l'album il ya déjà une
présentation globale et celle ci et là
il me fait une présentation que même
johnny aurait pas osé faire ce que je
veux dire c'est la dernière qui a fait
ça c'était katy perry et c'est vrai que
j'en parle parce qu'elle s'était elle
avait vendu des places une fortune
l'album a été un four et derrière
c'était très compliqué pour la tournée
parce que les gens avaient pris des
billets qu'ils pouvaient pas se faire
rembourser pour une tournée pour aller
écouter les chansons qu'il sera autre
chose